So Dr. Zakay to set the scene and to
give some context to this topic, what
reform would you want in the way of the
um in the modern world today when it
comes to following the Sunnah?
>> Alhamdulillah.
I welcome all of you with Islamic
greetings.
May peace, mercy and blessings of Allah
subhanaa tala be on all of you
regarding what reform I would want for
the present um in today's time. Of
course we had a two-day conference and
all what the speaker said is relevant to
it. But I would like to focus on one
point that's very important in reform.
Of course we cannot reform the sunnah.
The sunnah is the same. We have to go
back to the original sunnah. But
reforming the present ummah today even
if we agree that we will not go on that
point where Muslims are not following
sunnah I would like to go to that part
of the um where Muslims are following
sunnah what reform like first number one
the Muslim should be aware that amongst
the sunnah which is the most important
sunnah he should first try to do the
most important sunnah if he cannot do
then the second best then the or if he
wants to do five sunnas
in any particular act I'll come to it he
should try and do the best for example
the best the first question Allah will
ask you on day of judgment is about your
deeds and about your salah the most
important sunnah amongst all the far is
what after the faray which is the most
important sunnah the most important
sunnah after the far is
Is which can anyone tell me
which is the most important sunnah?
Number one sunnah after doing all your
minimum that you have to do.
The most important sunnah according to
me is the
most important indeed is salah after you
complete a five time salah. The most
important sunnah salah isam.
So if you want to offer any sunnah in
salah you should first try and offer and
the best time to offer in the last third
of the night. If you cannot then you
offer it in the early part after salah
the most important according to me and
according to the hadith is
if it's coupled with the salah you get
up in the last month of the night and
pray your salah it was further for the
prophet not for the um for us it is
mustahab
and for a it is more important so if a
Muslim comes and tells me I want to
offer sunnah salah I will offer the two
raat after voodoo is it a sunnah yes we
know the hadith ofam talking about may
Allah be pleased with him I don't want
to go into the detail it is a sunnah but
if someone says I want to offer the
sunnah it's good I'm not against it but
if he's going to offer only one sunnah
salah which is the most important
along with
okay I cannot offer I cannot wake up in
the middle Okay. Or for the with
after is the next important sunnah is
the sunnah before the fud salah. Our
beloved prophet said the two ra sunnah
before the fud is more valuable than the
world and the wealth in it.
Imagine. So which is more important the
taka after voodoo or raka before the faj
salah? So if you know the importance of
the sunnah salah you first try and do
the most important sunnah and by any way
you cannot do then try and do the second
best then the third best. So in salah
the most important is
couple is the best. Next important
sunnah is the two before the salah. Then
is the sun
which the two sunnah before is included.
Then the two plus two before the zor
salah two after the salah two after the
mak salah and two after the isha salah.
So first you follow the highly
recommended sunnah then the recommended
sunnah then the sunnah.
Sunnah can be divided into three broad
types if you want highly recommended
recommended and only sunnah. Then which
is the recommended sunnah? The prophet
said of
da I won't go into the details but time
is short. So next if you want to offer
after offering the sun which are 12 in a
day
these are all highly recommended sunnah.